We looked at positive powers. So let's check out some negative powers. A
negative exponent tells us to write the reciprocal of a base, and write it with
a positive power. So here the reciprocal of 3 is 1 3rd and then I write this
with a positive power of 2. This negative sign is kind of like an operation. It
tells us to write the reciprocal. Of our base. In the second example we need to
be careful, we have 5 times x to the negative 3. The exponent on the 5, is a
positive 1, so we're just going to list the 5 as a factor. Now, we take the
reciprocal of x, which is 1 over x, and then change the negative power to a
positive 3. For a fraction, we'll take the reciprocal of the base, which is 3
4ths, and change our negative 2, to a positive 2. We can simplify our answers to
get 1 9th, 5 divided by x cubed, and 9 16ths. Looking back at our work, we can
see that a negative exponent in a numerator moves the factor from the numerator,
to the denominator. The base of 3 was the numerator, and it ended in the
denominator. The same is true for the x and for the 4.